Декілька скибок хліба і твердого сиру,
маленький шматок м’яса,
пів яблука, шматочок шоколаду,
кілька овочів, склянка молока і дрібка круп –
приблизно таку денну норму продуктів можуть дозволити собі українці
на 2027 гривень прожиткового мінімуму.
Саме цю суму уряд заклав до державного бюджету
на 2020 рік як достатню для задоволення базових потреб.
При цьому - на які саме продукти харчування, товари та послуги
має вистачити цих грошей,
Кабінет міністрів взагалі не визначає.
Намагаємося з’ясувати це, провівши експеримент.
30-річна киянка Анна Журавська
погоджується пожити тиждень
на четвертину прожиткового мінімуму - а це 500 гривень.
Мені взагалі цікава тема економії в своєму житті,
також розумного споживання.
Зараз мені це актуально, тому що так вийшло,
що я звільняюся зі своєї основної роботи.
І мій дохід буде складати набагато меншу суму.
Вже до початку експерименту Анна усвідомлює:
жити у звичному для себе режимі ці 7 днів,
звісно, не зможе.
Це буде економія насамперед у їжі,
тобто буде дуже скромний набір продуктів, простий:
крупи, може трішечки овочів, не знаю.
Це буде відмова у каві.
Не ходити в якісь заклади харчування
і не купувати собі якісь...
розваги, а-ля книжку якусь чи одяг,
тому що це буде нереально.
Анна одразу відкладає 100 гривень на проїзд,
решта піде на їжу.
Аби вкластися в бюджет і мати більш-менш повноцінне харчування,
доводиться обирати дешеві товари і крупи на вагу.
Але прожитковий мінімум - це не просто сума,
на яку можна купити харчі,
а важливий фінансовий і соціальний показник,
який впливає на розподіл бюджету і конституційні права людей.
Адвокат Станіслав Батрин вже 5 років домагається у судах
встановлення справедливого розміру
прожиткового мінімуму.
Немає жодного паперу,
яким навіть підтверджується
розрахунок прожиткового мінімум в Україні.
Це є надзвичайна афера,
тепер ми би хотіли акцент поставити таким чином,
щоб люди розуміли, що від цього безпосередньо залежить
формування всього бюджету України.
Минулого року за позовом Станіслава
Верховний суд визнав незаконним
споживчий кошик, що офіційно затверджував перелік базових товарів та послуг.
А нещодавно Окружний адміністративний суд Києва
взагалі назвав ухвалення бюджету країни на 2020 рік протиправним,
бо міністри не провели експертизи та не сформували перелік
основних потреб і послуг, на яких він базується.
У дні, коли триває наш експеримент, уряд визнає:
на 2027 гривень у місяць в Україні не прожити.
І ухвалює проект закону, який у майбутньому дозволить
збільшити цю суму до 4200 гривень.
Більше 150 виплат, які прив’язані по прожиткового мінімуму.
Це і посадові оклади, зарплати, виплати у відрядженнях,
це пені і штрафи і так далі.
Ми запропонували законопроект комплексний,
який все, крім соціальних виплат,
відв’язує від поняття прожиткового мінімуму.
Якщо Верховна Рада підтримає цей проект закону,
то прожитковий мінімум зросте майже вдвічі
у порівнянні з нинішнім.
Але станеться це не раніше 1 січня 2021 року.
Тим часом, аби вкластися в нинішній мінімум,
Анна готує вдома більше, ніж зазвичай.
Аби не витрачати гроші на обід в кафе,
бере їжу з дому.
На каву з колегами теж не виходить.
Отже, покажу вам обід, який я взяла сьогодні в судочку.
В принципі я вважаю, що його собівартість приблизно 30 гривень,
додам цю суму до витрачених коштів.
Звичайно, якби купувала каву,  як я буває купую
з кавової машини, то було б дорожче, а так…
І якщо для Анни обмеження в їжі скІнчаться незалежно від результатів експерименту,
то майже 5 мільйонів українських пенсіонерів
живуть на пенсію від 1500 до 2000 тисяч гривень щомісячно.
Цих грошей не вистачає навіть тим, хто має своє господарство і городи.
Аби вижити, пані Ольга декілька разів на місяць
везе на продаж до столиці городину.
Доплачу за газ, за світло, щось на ліки витрачу - та й усе.
От вам і прожитковий мінімум.
А городи треба поорати, покультивувати.
Кажуть, чому дорога картопля?
А порахувати, скільки ми в неї вкладаємо.
Навіть після підняття прожиткового мінімуму через рік
для пані Ольги та мільйонів інших українців ситуація навряд чи суттєво зміниться.
На думку Станіслава Батрина, запропоновані урядом 4200 гривень -
вже станом на сьогодні сума неактуальна.
Ми виходили на цифру в 7 тисяч гривень.
Вона є публічною. Ми навіть у судовому порядку торкалися цього питання.
Однак мова не просто про цю цифру, мова про те, щоб держава
штучно і фіктивно не знижувала свій рівень відповідальності
за забезпечення потреб людини.
Наразі визначити цей рівень відповідальності держави взагалі неможливо,
бо де-юре в Україні після рішення Верховного Суду не існує споживчого кошику.
А де-факто у розрахунках спираються на перелік товарів, затверджений ще у 2016 році.
Він, окрім обмеженого продуктового набору,
передбачає,  приміром, одні брюки для жінок на 4 роки,
одні зимові чоботи раз на три роки,
два жарознижувальні препарати, один дитячий крем і один одеколон.
Шість книжок та одну передплату газети.
Про поповнення мобільного телефону, інтернет, похід у кіно чи поїздку на відпочинок
хоча б раз на рік, взагалі не йдеться.
Не купуючи нічого, окрім їжі і жетонів на метро,
бюджетно пообідавши декілька разів не вдома,
Анна Журавська була змушена передчасно припинити експеримент.
Гроші скінчилися на шостий день.
Вистачало суто на їжу, при чому не на їжу,
а на таке базове харчування і на проїзд. Все!
На все інше - на ліки, піти до лікаря
чи там на масаж, бо в мене зі спиною якраз були проблеми,
чи там в кіно сходити, чи книжку, чи якийсь подарунок придбати,
я вже мовчу про комунальні послуги.
За словами міністра соціальної політики Юлії Соколовської,
чотири міністерства вже розпочали спільну роботу над формуванням
нового споживчого кошика українців.
Але як саме визначатимуться товари та послуги
в ньому, поки що невідомо.